die stadt der ratsche die front ist hier
im nordosten der ukraine nur sieben
kilometer entfernt jederzeit kann
russisches artilleriefeuer einschlagen
wir folgen dem postauto von soja der
briefträgerin wenn es ruhig ist fährt
sieht die post aus
ich bin glücklich dass ich zu den
menschen kommen kann zu den alten
menschen sie sind wie eine zweite
familie
ich liebe sie und sie lieben mich es ist
ein beidseitiges gefühl
für viele menschen ist sie der einzige
besuch der loch kommt hannah wohnt seit
56 jahren in ihrem haus sie hat acht
verwandte im krieg verloren die 87
jährige lebt jetzt allein
es gibt jetzt nur noch wenige nachbarn
hier und die sehe ich kaum wegen der
angriffe
der zaun gegen kaputt und es kamen viele
hunde in den garten und einer hat mich
ins bein gebissen
umgerechnet 80 euro beträgt ihre rente
im monat soja zahlt sie aus das geld
reicht kaum für strom und ihre
medikamente wenigstens ausreichend zu
essen hat
ich habe die hungersnot von 1947
überlebt damals bin ich auf bäume
geklettert
es gab in der ganzen gegend keine
kirschen mehr
wir haben die blätter gegessen wir haben
das überlebt aber jetzt unmöglich wir
können kaum in den garten gehen und
wasser holen wenn die bomben vom himmel
fallen wie können wir so leben
kann das letzte stütze ist die postbotin
der sommer ist kurz im nordosten der
ukraine das haus durch den beschuss
nicht mehr winterfest soja weiß dass sie
die einzige ist die sich um hilfe
kümmern kann
poststelle 62 302 s kommen private
hilfspakete von geflüchteten an
dieses hier aus der slowakei die banken
sind wegen des krieges geschlossen auch
die rente gibt es jetzt nur noch über
die post
briefträgerin soja beliefert die
umliegenden straßen mit dem fahrrad
es leben noch 18.000 menschen in der
haci ein viertel der ursprünglichen
bevölkerung alle anderen sind geflohen
das kulturhaus im stadtzentrum
zerstört wie die hauptfiliale der post
ich nehme mich die menschen haben sich
verändert sie haben keine angst mehr
ich habe diese stadt nie verlassen ich
habe immerhin in der haci gelebt meine
alte mutter ist hier mein bruder und
meine tochter
sie arbeitet in unserem krankenhaus
ich habe nur angst um meine mutter
soja arbeitet seit 20 jahren als
postbotin nie sagt sie wurde sie so
gebraucht wie jetzt im krieg
wir verlassen der haci
das anlegen der schutzwesten kein
angenehmes gefühl auch weil die menschen
hier eben keine haben doch die straße
ist gefährlich wir fahren zum treffpunkt
mit den ukrainischen soldaten die tote
russische kämpfer einsammeln
ein abstellgleis irgendwo beitrag if den
genauen standort dürfen wir nicht nennen
anton führt die ukrainische
militäreinheit j9 an seine aufgabe ist
es gefallen russische soldaten zu bergen
die zurückgelassen wurden anton hat zwei
monate lang seine stadt raki verteidigt
dort ist er geboren und aufgewachsen
wir behandeln alle gefallenen russischen
soldaten nach den regeln des
völkerrechts
das ist unser land wir
sind hier geboren wir werden an keinen
anderen ort gehen wir brauchen kein
anderes land außer unseres wir sind hier
zu hause
es geht zur not ostfront der einheit
wurde ein leichenfund gemeldet im
umkämpften gebiet wird reden schnell und
mit kleiner kamera
kommt und habt euch den gleichen sagen
ein bisschen schnell sein
es ist ein widerspruch den der krieg
hervorbringt sie riskieren ihr leben um
den leichnamen des feindes die letzte
würde zu geben
sie wissen um die gefahr um minen und
sprengfallen
mit jedem schritt nimmt der geruch der
verwesung zu
brandort dokumentiert den leichnam der
tote russische soldat muss schon lange
hier gelegen haben
wirklich enden werde der krieg erst sagt
uns anton später auf der rückfahrt wenn
der letzte veteran gestorben sei die
erinnerung werden in uns weiterleben
über 100 leichen hat er mit seinen
kameraden bereits geborgen teils unter
beschuss es ist wichtig die leichen
können solchen auslösen sie helfen die
russische propaganda zu entlarven und
die so gesammelten daten können bei der
aufklärung von kriegsverbrechen nützlich
sein
selbst während kampfhandlungen
evakuieren und identifizieren wir die
leichname unserer feinde keine armee hat
dies zuvor so akribisch getan die
einhaltung des völkerrechts ist ihm
wichtig auch weil er im krieg versucht
seinen moralischen kompass zu wahren
doch mitgefühl mit den gefallenen russen
das empfindet er nicht
wir haben sie getötet was könnte besser
sein
den austausch der toten soldaten mit
russland organisiert das internationale
rote kreuz details seien geheim sagt
anton
zurück zu soja der briefträgerin ihre
nächste kundin wohnt den hausnummer 53
es ist wieder doch die rente kann nicht
mehr ausgezahlt werden ihrer sei bereits
vor ein paar tagen gestorben erfährt so
ja
sie ist tot das passiert nicht so oft
und es ist doch früher mal geschehen
normalerweise informieren uns nachbarn
oder die kinder
sie rufen uns an und waren uns vor dafür
bin ich ihnen sehr dankbar
soja behält das geld ein die pension
geht zurück an den start es geht zur
letzten kundin an diesem tag im
außenbezirk von der hat simons vitaler
auch sie rentnerin die ihr heim nicht
verlassen will
wir sind hier sehr glücklich mit unserer
postboten sie ist großartig freundlich
und höflich und gebildet und sie liefert
immer pünktlich aus
dass mit der pünktlichkeit entspricht
nicht ganz der wahrheit aber dass soja
die postbotin überhaupt kommt inmitten
des krieges das rechtfertigt ins
mittelmaß augen jede art von lob
[Musik]